make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Robin and
I've actually got a podcast I don't
think a lot of you guys know that it's
just called the Rob Jefferson show I
couldn't really think of a simpler name
besides that the Rob Jefferson show so
the way this podcast is set up as a lot
of you guys know I've been trying to
keep comics explained as a channel
that's like my main thing rightly I love
to unconcious playing left talking about
comics but I've also been delving into
like other things outside of comics as
well right so I can kind of you know
explore my hobbies and the things that I
like and you guys can join me along that
journey so the Rob Jefferson show is an
hour long split into two parts the first
half an hour basically deals with comic
books and comic book movies right so
like you know one of the more recent
episodes we talked about how to put Nova
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe and an
episode before that or I think in
episode after that actually we talked
about Kevin Feige being promoted to
chief creative officer at Marvel which
is a huge promotion meaning he's over
everything at Marvel basically like
Marvel TV shows and mobile comics or at
least the creator side of it anyway um
and then for the second half an hour we
split it between a combination of
talking about gaming related topics
right so like in the most recent episode
we talked about the release of call of
duty modern warfare and then we
basically round it out with like life
advice stuff you know different you know
different things that we all struggle
with everyday and so on and so forth
because the overall hope of the podcast
is to maintain that comic book theme
right I don't want to walk away from
comics entirely but to also focus on
other things that you guys deal with
because you guys are about you guys are
dynamic and you guys are unique you guys
are not just coming put people right you
guys love videogames and you guys had
yes struggle with things over the course
of your life and and so on and so forth
and I want the podcast to be able to
include all those things you know to
really resonate with you guys on
multiple levels so it's not just comic
books uh but having said that the the
the podcast itself is on iTunes it's on
Spotify it's on SoundCloud and it's on
the Google Play Store right so what's on
all of those you'll find the links for
all four down in the description we're
like three or four episodes in I love
doing it it's a blast it's really really
awesome but nonetheless so so Galactus
that's what you guys are here for why
you guys are here for Galactus you guys
are here for this this this whole thing
about Galactus here's the thing here's
the best thing about fan theories right
well there's there's two great things
that come out of fan theories one is is
a fact that we just kind of let our
imaginations run wild right when it
comes to fan theories and to every fan
theory inevitably boils down to an
argument about comic books it always
happens right like you guys know exact
I'm talking about it always happens like
like either you're doing it or I'm doing
it or like even in the comments section
I see it all the time like I'll see
somebody will post something and they'll
say like man this character would be
super Opie for for you know for the the
NSE you and then like three or four
people will respond kind of saving their
their scenarios and then I'll come back
like two days later and the comment
thread will be like twenty or thirty
comments long and at the end of it it's
just like no way the Silver Surfer can
be blue bar
and it's hilarious it's hilarious to see
but but I think that when it comes to
Galactus in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe all these fan theories are
amazing like they're they're absolutely
awesome right there's one fan theory
that says and what I can't really
exactly link to it but I suppose I came
over the exact person but I'll is it's
something spiral zero zero from reddit
I'll post a link to it down in the
description but there's one theory that
a lot of you guys are probably aware of
this said that like Galactus was a
back-up plan of Thanos right that the
idea was that Thanos wanted to wipe out
half the life of the universe but Thanos
was not an idiot right he was just kinda
like okay so if I wipe out half the life
in the universe eventually the
population will get back to where it is
now so in order to keep that from
happening
I'm gonna create a being whose sole
purpose is to basically cruise around
the universe and and basically keep the
population of the universe at half of
what it is now
what is actually a genius idea and it's
probably one of the best theories I've
ever heard on how to put Galactus in the
MCU there's another theory that said
that the snap of fan o's woke up the
likeness in the quantum realm and as
much as I love these theories I think
that in a lot of ways it's kind of
overthinking it right I mean it's it's
cool but I feel like it's kind of
overthinking it I think if if I'm the
MCU right like if I'm Kevin Feige or any
one of the creative people who are
working at the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and they're saying how do you poke a lot
this in the MCU either they come to me
and they say how do you put them like
this in the MCU or all I just say he
just wakes off that's really all it is
like Thanos chitter I'm sorry Galactus
just wakes up just comes to and now he's
walking around the universe consuming
half the life in it and and there's
precedent for that right that precedent
comes from two sources really if you
decided to win just say the Thanos woke
Galactus up by virtue of the events of
the end of an infinity war when he when
he initiated the snap and Avengers
endgame then you could basically use
that using an existing precedent in
Marvel Comics or you can just say go
like just woke up using another
precedent right so you're going with
going with the first one saying the life
is just wakes up in the universe this
just goes into his origin right that's
really all it is
um in in Marvel Comics where if you're
going to read the old Thor stories by
Walt Simonson which is the first time
that you get the origin of Galactus what
you end up finding out is of course
whereas most of you those guys who know
about this bear with me for a second
this is for the people who don't
Galactus basically doesn't just a space
explorer named Galan right now he was a
guy who was trying to figure out why his
universe was coming to an end it wasn't
until much later on with the adventures
of the x-men miniseries the Marvel
explained what was actually happening
and that Galactus just didn't really
know what was what was going on the way
you two played out there was a bean
called the dweller in darkness who
existed in a dimension called ever nigh
and the idea here was the dweller of
Darkness wanted to basically wipe out
all things in existence and then merge
with the sentience of the universe and
then be reborn as a new being who just
had this astronomical amount of power
and so what the dweller in darkness did
was it fractured something called the
m'kraan crystal
think of the m'kraan crystal is a giant
hallway of doors is all it is each door
leading to a different universe the
difference is that if you were to
fracture the crystal or crack one of the
doors or smash the door down literally
everything would just start getting
sucked inside the crystal and the entire
multiverse would just collapse ends
inside the crystal itself and then would
explore it outward in a Big Bang with
the recreation of everything that's what
ended up happening with regards to the
regards to the multiverse as it existed
at the time the result was a gallon
didn't know that right gallon just knew
the universe was coming to an end and he
was trying to figure out a way to stop
it ultimately he couldn't and so as the
universe was winding down and as it was
all coming to a close he merged with
that universes sentience of the universe
and that in turn was reborn into the
main Marvel Universe as Galactus but the
difference here is he wasn't reborn and
then went on a crusade to consume half
the lot you know all the life and all
these various planets and things like
that it took him like billions of years
to get to that point right like he
literally just sat in this spaceship
that had been that he had really this
kind of cosmic egg he just sat in there
like for billions and billions of years
learning how to control his energies
learning how to how to basically harness
himself and the result was that when he
finally emerged after like three or four
billion years he went forward to sort of
consuming you know all these different
life-sustaining planets across the
universe in order to maintain his
energies all you do is you expand that
time out and you just say well Galactus
is just now showing up right it took him
you know 13 billion years to emerge as
opposed to three billion years and
you're off to the races done it's a
super easy explanation for the
introduction of Galactus and it's no
muss no fuss right I mean people who are
coming book readers and know the origin
of Galactus will look at that and say
okay so like basically you took a little
bit longer than normal right Galactus he
he got really caught up watching
watching like I don't know watching some
TV show watching rhythm was it was it uh
rhythm what is that show it's the it's
the rap show it's amazing it's on
Netflix uh we're the rhythm and beats I
think it is he was watching that where
he was like really caught up in Golden
Girls
you could nail people will look at that
fans will look at that and say okay so
it just took longer and for the average
movie-going audience those though except
for they'll be like okay I mean that
works and they'll just go go with it
right so that's a super easy explanation
the introduction of characters like the
Silver Surfer they could do tyrunt if
they wanted to you can do all that right
now
right I mean tire it was a Herald of
Galactus that he ultimately lost control
of and then he imprisoned in the kiln
until Thanos freed him there's it's a
story I think called Thanos cosmic
powers and it's it's the story sounds
cooler than it is to be honest but
basically Thanos ends up going on this
crusade fighting like the most powerful
beings in the Marvel Universe that she
does sound really cool I should probably
cover that I feel like one of the other
coming with youtubers is gonna be like
I'm covering that now and then like
they're gonna make videos on it but
nonetheless it's that's that's a super
easy explanation and I think it's the
best one I think it's the one that works
the easiest because it's it's it's basic
but if you decided to go with the idea
that that Thanos won't Galactus up there
is precedence for that right and that
comes by virtue of the villain
apocalypse so a Marvel Comics a lot of
the guys I've heard of a story called
House of M right and most of you guys
have heard the name even if you don't
know the ins and outs of the story
itself right in the general gist of this
was that the Scarlet Witch went crazy
she will I don't really I mean she did
go crazy but Quicksilver was the one who
talked her into it
but she ended up basically taking
Charles Xavier reading his mind figuring
out the subconscious thoughts of
everybody on earth and then recreating
all of reality in order to give
everybody their subconscious desires
right so like magneto was was basically
like the top mutant in the world and
mutants ruled over humanity dr. strange
was a psychiatrist which is kind of
weird there's one point where he's
talking to the century and the century
is talking about the void and and it's
literally like just one little one-off
thing it's just like Doctor Strange like
and how does that make you feel and
that's that's what you get that's all
you get in terms of what it is
doing but like Harold Danvers is the
most popular superhero on earth in
comparison to the main Marvel Universe
where she's not really popular at all
there are a lot of things that were
going on with regards to those
characters but ultimately it all gets
set back to rights
you know like scarlet which basically
says no more mutants think the universe
goes back to the way it was before
except 98% of the mutant population have
lost their powers as a result of that
because there was such a huge plummet in
the mutant population the villain
apocalypse woke up and and this matters
because apocalypse is a is a super
powerful character right he's so
powerful the x-men have never really
been able to defeat him they've only
ever been able to run like keep him at
bay would fight him off for a little
while and he's like whatever man he's
gonna leave and always begged the
question why didn't he just annihilate
them which he could he didn't actually
in the animated series there's an
episode where he grossed like 2,000 feet
tall and just incinerates the x-men it's
the coolest thing ever he's just like
x-men Wow I don't like that's the end of
it they're dead they get annihilated
like one fell swoop is the coolest thing
ever
but regardless of the scenario
apocalypse because he's so powerful has
to basically go dormant for periods of
time right so like he'll basically go
into a sleep and he'll reside there for
maybe like a thousand years maybe 2,000
years maybe for five hundred years it
depends but then like once his energies
of recharge to a wake up and he'll go
back to his existence as being a person
that basically implements social
Darwinism right so like taking different
different cultures or societies and
pitting them against each other to
eliminate the weak in those societies to
figure out who the strongest is on earth
at the time oh you do that exact same
thing with Galactus right all you do is
you say that like Galactus has been
dormant this whole time because he's
basically been coalescing or resting or
whatever it is and he has been since the
universe was formed and the actions of
Thanos and wiping out half the life in
the universe really said this kind of
cascade this shockwave throughout the
entirety of the universe and woke up the
likeness like holy crap what was that
you know and then just like he ends on
you know because of the fact that he's
awake
he's essentially exceedingly hungry and
then starts going across the universe
consuming life-sustaining planets right
you could do that I mean it's pretty
simple I wouldn't go as far as to say
that Galactus resided inside the quantum
realm and that this woke him up and
brought him out but you could just
simply say that like it woke him up I
think the first theory is probably the
most reasonable and the easiest one to
go with is the simplest one to do the
MCU really prides itself on on you know
giving us various iterations of kind of
a characters and teams and the simplest
and most straightforward way possible is
what they're really known for and
there's been a recipe for success is a
twenty six billion dollar franchise so
obviously they're doing something right
but the fact remains here you know it's
it's this is an interesting thing right
I mean this is by no means an absolutely
right I mean yeah one of the things you
guys are gonna learn about how much
explain you know is is I try my best to
give you guys all the most accurate
information well I'm human just like
everybody else and I get things wrong so
uh so the theories are by no means meant
to be taken as fact right it's just kind
of my stance on things and and how I
think the easiest way to roll things in
now and maybe there's this theories
already floating out there somewhere
right I wouldn't be so arrogant as to
say like I'm the only person who ever
thought of this I don't know that so I'm
not gonna tell you that but the theory
may have been maybe floating out there
already I don't really know but I think
that's the most reasonable way to do it
to basically say that Galactus has just
been dormant all this time and Thanos
wiping out half life the universe had
nothing to do with him waking up he just
ended up waking up at some future point
in time and now he's going around the
universe consuming all these
life-sustaining worlds and then
ultimately he needs a herald because
it's just too too you know exhausting on
him to do it on his own and so he ends
up creating like the tyrant or the
Silver Surfer if you just want to skip
over tyrant or any one of those other
heroes that came after frankie ray and
and different things like that
Terrax the tamer and so on but
regardless of circumstance i think it's
cool i think it's a cool little simple
theory let me know what you guys think
down in the comment section with that
being said we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you guys are new here too
comments explained make sure you guys to
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]